[موسيقى]
أنا على وشك ركوب إحدى العبارات الأخيرة التي
تعمل بين
مدينتي ماكاو وهونغ كونغ شبه المستقلتين
وذلك لأن حكومة مدينة هونغ كونغ
قد أعلنت للتو أنها
ستعلق هذه الخدمة اعتبارًا من منتصف الليل
بالتوقيت المحلي  يوم الاثنين ، وهو جزء
من الجهود المبذولة لمحاولة وقف انتشار
فيروس كورونا القاتل ، إنه أيضًا
قرار يحدث وسط
ضغوط سياسية محلية كبيرة
لأن نقابة تمثل العاملين في المجال الطبي
قد هددت بالإضراب
إذا كانت المعابر الحدودية بين هونغ.
لم يتم إغلاق كونغ وبقية الصين
الآن ، خدمة العبارات هذه ، أعني
أنها وسيلة نقل رئيسية
بين ماكاو وهونغ كونغ ، حيث عبر عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص هذا الطريق
كل شهر ، وهناك أشخاص
يتنقلون من العمل بين هاتين
المستعمرتين الأوروبيتين السابقتين و  التي
وصلت الآن إلى التوقف ، إنه مثال على كيفية
عزل أجزاء مختلفة من الصين
عن بعضها البعض في محاولة
لوقف الانتشار  د للمرض وبينما
يحدث هذا ، توقف الحكومات وشركات
الطيران أيضًا
رحلات الطيران والطائرات إلى أجزاء من الصين في
محاولة لمنع فيروس كورونا
من الوصول إلى دول أخرى ، وتنصح
المزيد والمزيد من الدول
مواطنيها بعدم القيام بذلك.  السفر هنا إلى
البر الرئيسي للصين مع تكثيف البلاد
لجهودها الهائلة لاحتواء
تفشي فيروس كورونا القاتل ، تمنع الولايات المتحدة
وأستراليا أيضًا الرعايا الأجانب
الذين سافروا إلى الصين في
الأسبوعين الماضيين من دخول
بلدانهم المواطنون الأمريكيون الذين
سافروا إلى هوبي الصينية  المقاطعة ، التي كانت
بؤرة تفشي فيروس كورونا
في الأسبوعين السابقين لعودتهم
إلى الولايات المتحدة ، ستخضع لما يصل إلى 14 يومًا
من الحجر الصحي الإلزامي ، يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
إنه أول حجر صحي إلزامي
في الولايات المتحدة منذ أكثر من 50 عامًا
للمسافرين الأمريكيين العائدين
من  قد تخضع بقية البر الرئيسي للصين
لفحوصات صحية لمدة تصل إلى
أسبوعين من الحجر الصحي الذاتي داخل
الصين  تكثف معظم الحكومات المحلية
جهود الاحتواء
أيضًا يوم السبت ، بدأت مدينة هونغ كونغ
في تقييد السكان من مغادرة
منازلهم تنفيذًا لهذا الأمر الذي
يتطلب من الأشخاص الذين يعيشون في وسط المدينة
تعيين فرد واحد فقط من أفراد الأسرة
يمكنه مغادرة منازلهم.  في المنزل
كل يومين لشراء البقالة ،
سيكون الاستثناء هو أولئك الذين يحتاجون إلى
علاج طبي وأولئك الذين يعملون في
الصيدليات ومحلات السوبر ماركت التي
تؤثر على الفور على 400000 شخص ولكن
المجتمعات المحيطة
يوصى بتنفيذ نفس السياسة التي من شأنها أن
تشمل 7.5 مليون شخص وهذا أكثر
من عدد السكان  في ولاية
أريزونا ، أصبحت الصين معزولة بشكل متزايد
عن العالم ، حيث تقوم 62
دولة على الأقل بتنفيذ مجموعة واسعة
من قيود الهجرة ضد
المواطنين الصينيين والأشخاص الذين يسافرون
من الصين القارية نتيجة لذلك فإن هذا
البلد الذي يبلغ عدد سكانه 1.4 مليار شخص يخضع بشكل
أساسي للحجر الصحي ديفيد كولفر
سي إن إن بكين
[موسيقى]